unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are influencing the
news you read
download the ground news app for free at
davidpakman.comground
so yesterday was day two of donald
trump's second impeachment trial monday
day one was
a full day of debate as to whether the
senate actually has the jurisdiction
to try a former president they decided
yes we do by a 56 to 44 vote
uh so yesterday was sort of like the
first real day with
eight hours going to the prosecution we
saw all sorts of different presentations
including presentations with videos from
um the january 6th riots some of which
we'll review
later video that was previously not seen
video that showed
just how close of a call it was for a
lot of members of the house and senate
avoiding these riotous
violent mobs incited by donald trump and
you would think
that even though most republicans have
already prejudged this impeachment trial
most republicans have already decided
they're going to be voting to acquit
regardless of what's going on
you might have thought that they'd have
at least pretended to be paying
attention
pretended to be weighing the
presentations and making some kind of a
decision based on the evidence that was
there
but they had the benefit that the
cameras
did not show the chamber at any time
during the proceedings the cameras as we
saw during yesterday's live streams and
much of the media coverage
were focused in quite tightly on
the presenter the various house
impeachment managers who had
turns to speak yesterday and we were
left to rely
on reports of members of the media in
the chamber to tell us what exactly were
senators doing during what
are very long days of presentations and
it turns out that
many republicans were engaged in
everything from drawing
doodles to sneaking in
ipads as chuck grassley reportedly did
in order to be able to read other
material
unclear exactly what it was while the
presentations were going on a business
insider has a nice
sort of compilation of different reports
about this and they say that many
senators were distracting themselves
yesterday afternoon when the
democratic impeachment managers were
laying out the case
rand paul who at many points appeared to
be
the only person in the chamber not
wearing a mask he was doodling
and according to one report drew a
picture of what appeared to be the
capital i guess
almost like architectural tribes of some
kind according to reporters in the room
during a long
stretch of the presentation rand paul
wasn't even
in the room but at one point when the
proceedings went to a break rand paul
reportedly ran back in
and gave a note to trump's attorney
david shone that's according to an abc
news reporter
named allison peckerin a cynthia lummus
who's a wyoming republican
at certain points was not wearing a mask
as well manu raju reporting that rand
paul wasn't even at his desk for much of
the 1 pm
hour that was a key hour of
presentations
from the house impeachment managers nbc
news was able to report that senator
mike braun
was sleeping during certain parts of the
presentation this is not like they
slept through metaphorically mike braun
was
literally asleep during part of these
presentations
uh rick scott at one point was looking
at a map
of what appeared to be southeast asia
unclear if he was
catching up on the geopolitical
implications of the borders in asia or
maybe
figuring out where he wanted to go on an
upcoming trip a senator josh hawley who
was one of the main players in voting
against the certification of a number of
different votes on january 6th
at one point was leaning back with his
feet up on the back of a seat
in front of him very remember when
barack obama put his feet up on the desk
in the oval office and it was
a big scandal almost as big a scandal as
when he wore a tan suit or liked the
wrong mustard
and republicans said you don't put your
feet up in the in the oval office well
senator josh hawley
with his feet up on the seat in front of
him in the senate
and uh he appeared to be reading
documents
um unrelated to the impeachment trial
and he said he was reading trial briefs
um so this is i mean listen um
if this were you know a lot of a lot of
republicans have been making the case
that there's too much
about this trial that's not happening
the way a real trial would happen in a
court of law
for example many republicans have taken
issue with the fact that
democratic senator patrick leahy was
is not only presiding over the
impeachment trial
but will also be a juror in that he is
one of the hundred votes
on the conviction or acquittal of donald
trump and
senator patrick leahy also is in a sense
a witness
because he was there on january 6. now
the witness thing would apply to every
single one of these
senators since they were all there on
january 6. so that
seems to be neither here nor there but
one of the other
important differences between a quote
real trial in a court of law and what's
going on here is that if
normal jurors were reading on ipads
sleeping reading documents related to
other matters
during a trial they would be removed
from a case
and it could even potentially lead to a
mistrial depending on what the
circumstances were
in a normal jury many of the individuals
would be disqualified not
potentially because they were so-called
witnesses but because they were part
of the alleged crime that took place
uh what i mean by that is that many of
the senators that will be jurors
ted cruz josh hawley and others
were actually part of the two-month
campaign
of claiming that the election was stolen
by joe biden from donald trump
that led to the january sixth riots in
the first place they were
essentially part of the conspiracy uh
with the defendant in this case donald
trump so
there's a lot to sort through here but i
would hope
that everybody would be able to see that
sent reports of senators sleeping and
senators sneaking in ipads and say
listen
that's not right even if they ultimately
are going to vote to acquit
they should be paying attention but
unfortunately there are
lots of right wingers defending this
saying it's a kangaroo court
it's a sham it's ridiculous it's
meaningless it shouldn't even be
happening so good for these senators for
literally sleeping through it
it's stunning that this is what's going
on it's stunning that these are the 100
100 of the most powerful people in the
united states and some of them are
napping
literally napping during the proceedings
we'll see today how it continues
uh i don't expect uh rand paul to change
his behavior
i don't expect chuck grassley to change
his behavior and we'll get into some of
the meat of what was presented yesterday
which was
truly stunning to see we
predicted that the southern district of
new york
prosecution a district attorney
would be a thorn in the side of donald
trump and his family
long after he was out of office that may
still be the case but it is georgia
that is jumping ahead very quickly and
has launched a criminal investigation
into donald trump's
supposedly perfect phone call to georgia
officials
saying that they need to find 11 780
votes for him
yes donald trump is under criminal
investigation it's happening
even more quickly than some of us
anticipated it might happen the new york
times reporting
that prosecutors in georgia have started
a criminal probe
into donald trump's attempts to overturn
the election results in
georgia including that infamous phone
call he made
to republican secretary of state brad
raffensberger that's the call
where trump insisted i only need eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes
what are we going to do
help me out here how can we find these
votes
uh fanny willis who is the
democratic prosecutor in fulton county
has now sent a letter to numerous
officials in state government including
brad raffensberger
requesting that documents be preserved
related to an investigation
into attempts to influence the state's
2020 presidential election so this is
notable for a few different reasons
these notifications to preserve
documents are typical
when there is an investigation that is
taking place
because this is a prosecutor in fulton
county
we know that this is a criminal
investigation that's what it is that's
what it means that's what these
prosecutors
investigate now the letter does not
mention donald trump by name
um but it is related to what donald
trump
did trying to change the outcome of
georgia's election
insisting that these uh officials
should simply find these votes make it
happen
and a copy of this letter that was sent
was obtained by the new york times and
it really
doesn't look good for donald trump now
the
speculation is trump's ultimately going
to be charged with felony election fraud
and that one of the really important um
things to understand is that when it
comes to these statutes
even if you fail to convince someone to
do the thing you want them to do
it is still a crime quote under georgia
law
it is illegal to falsify any records
used in connection with an election
or to place false entries in such
records and
any person who solicits requests
commands importance or otherwise
attempts to cause
the other person to falsify election
fraud in the first degree
uh to falsify voting records is guilty
of criminal solicitation to commit
election fraud in the first degree
this is a felony offense and much like
with bribery if you try to bribe someone
and they don't accept the bribe
you're still guilty uh if you i mean
listen when we talk about attempted
murder just because you failed to kill
someone doesn't mean you've committed no
crime and much the same way
even if you fail to induce fraud by
asking someone in this case brad
raffensberger
to find these eleven thousand seven
hundred and eighty votes
you are still culpable even if you don't
get them to do the thing you're asking
them to do
imagine if georgia ruins donald trump's
life before new york does
everyone expecting southern district of
new york to be the
never-ending thorn and trump side and
georgia jumping ahead very quickly now
from the standpoint of trump's defense
the president the former president is
known for not paying bills of all kinds
in real estate not paying contractors
that he hires to do windows or whatever
it is he needs at different buildings
as a president known for not paying
legal fees who's going to defend donald
trump
and is it still worth it to them to do
it simply to say you're defending the
president
even if you're not going to get paid is
it worth it for the notoriety is it not
worth it for the publicity and the pr i
don't know the answer
but it seems as though donald trump is
going to need a lot a lot of different
lawyers
over the next several years this is just
the start and
uh you know i think from the standpoint
of setting expectations
we know what the defense will be about
fine 780
11 780 votes and we talked about this on
the bonus show yesterday
um it is going to be donald trump wasn't
asking someone to commit fraud
donald trump really believed this is
what they'll say we don't know if it's
the truth
donald trump really believed he won in
the state of georgia
and what he was pointing out was it was
only 11
780 votes of margin and that
what trump was saying was we don't need
to fix
every fraudulent vote we just need to
fix eleven thousand seven hundred and
eighty it will go to donald trump's
mindset at the time it will go to donald
trump's beliefs at the time
i have no uh delusion that this would be
an
easy case to prove and i've had a number
of lawyers email me about this reality
similar similar to with perjury
just because you said something untrue
under oath doesn't mean
it's necessarily perjury you have to
prove intent
and that's why it's very difficult to
prove perjury that's why you don't often
see it
prosecuted when incorrect statements are
made
under oath during trials and the same
complexity will come up here that
doesn't mean trump won't need lawyers to
defend him he will
and the question of who is it going to
be i can't imagine it's going to be
bruce castor
i don't think david shone would be
interested in this one nor nor do i
think it's a specialty
so the next months and years are going
to be very interesting but for today
yes a criminal investigation apparently
launched
by georgia into donald trump's
supposedly perfect phone call that's his
designation
nobody else is calling it that and we
will see where that goes
tell me what you expect in terms of
these investigations criminal civil and
otherwise
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation is one of the
biggest problems that our society faces
and online
filter bubbles make the problem worse
making it difficult even for intelligent
news consumers to figure out what's true
and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first
news comparison platform that lets you
compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me
easily see how different news outlets
are manipulating a story to fit their
own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021
with a balanced news diet download the
ground news app for
free by going to davidpakman.com
ground the link is right underneath this
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily made possible
by viewers and listeners who sign up for
a membership at joinpacman.com it's
quick it's easy you get extra stuff
every single day and you can use the
coupon code better21
to get a discount off of the membership
of your choice
uh sign up at joinpakman.com let's look
at some interesting posts
uh that i saw this morning on the david
pakman show subreddit which you can find
at davidpakman.com reddit
more than uh what is the number now more
than 28 000
viewers and listeners of the show now
subscribed to the subreddit
at davidpakman.com reddit a lot of
people writing to me after the first
day of the trump impeachment trial
number two
about the so-called chewbacca defense
after seeing
attorney bruce castor rant for 50
minutes trump's attorney bruce castor
ran for 50 minutes about
vinyl records that his parents liked the
political preferences of his parents
his friends in the senate and what kind
of relationships he has with them
a pre-revolutionary british law and all
sorts of things that have nothing to do
whatever
with the impeachment trial i got a bunch
of emails from people saying was that
the chewbacca defense and scrappy do
posted this uh to the subreddit saying
who believes that bruce castor
was attempting to use the chewbacca
defense
during yesterday's portion of former
president trump's
impeachment trial and pointing out that
bruce castor's speech was just
random facts and irrelevant things
to the actual defense of donald trump
and
indeed the chewbacca defense is
a legal strategy there's actually an
entire wiki page
about the chewbacca defense the
chewbacca defense is a legal strategy
when a criminal lawyer just tries to
confuse the jury
instead of refuting the case and the
reason that this can work in criminal
trials is
we have this standard of reasonable
doubt
and if a defense attorney can introduce
reasonable doubt any kind of reasonable
doubt
then they are a significant step closer
to securing an acquittal
for their client and so the idea of a
chewbacca defense would be
a prosecution comes together and makes a
case that's relevant and it's germane
uh to the facts and the complaint that
is being adjudicated
and a defense attorney can introduce
irrelevant facts stories confusion
and if you can get the jurors just
saying well
we had the case from the prosecution and
then we had the case from the defense
even if the case from the defense was
irrelevant and didn't make any sense
if it makes the jurors feel as though
there's some kind of doubt as to what
happened
even if it's because the defense lawyer
was talking about chewbacca
star wars vinyl records and whatever you
can
turn what might be a very good case for
the prosecution
uh into a confusing enough case that
maybe you get a juror to say i think
we've got to go with not guilty because
i'm still even confused about what it is
that took place that's the
that's the idea of the chewbacca defense
now it shouldn't
really apply um to a senate impeachment
trial
where the standards are different it is
not a criminal proceeding it is a
political proceeding
uh the jury is not you know six or
twelve of one's peers
it's 100 u.s senators so in any case
that's the back story on the chewbacca
defense and it is in practice i don't
know that bruce castor deliberately
planned to go up there
and do a chewbacca defense but it's
ultimately what ended up taking place
another interesting post on the
subreddit this morning
uh about the second impeachment where
user hohh231
said the second impeachment will be like
the movie groundhog day
same type of honestly presented facts by
democrats as in the first
impeachment followed by the same lame
falsehoods
and distractions by republicans as in
the first impeachment
same disappointing results still needs
to happen though
and i hope i'm wrong about the results
now you know in the first impeachment
i was saying pretty early trump's not
getting convicted
and we knew that because we knew that
they weren't going to have the votes
you need 17 republicans to say i'm going
to vote to convict
and we thought there might be somewhere
between one and four and in the end mitt
romney voted to convict on one of the
two
counts much the same way i know that
people get mad at me when i say this and
they've been emailing me this week
saying david why are you
prejudging what's going on and saying
there won't be a conviction
it's because we know that maybe there
would be
five very optimistically five or six
republicans that might vote to convict
uh on the single count in in question
here in the current impeachment trial
but we just know democrats don't have
the numbers we just
know i would love to be able to tell you
that it's too early
because every republican is going in
there planning to
evaluate the case made by the
impeachment managers and evaluate the
case made by donald trump's
attorneys and then going to decide by
weighing the evidence
but that's not what they're going to do
we know that that's not what what
they're going to do
and remember that 44 members of the
senate already said they don't even
believe the senate
has the jurisdiction to do this trial
do you think they're really open to
voting to convict donald trump of course
not so
i know some people don't like it but
it's the reality and
uh donald trump will be acquitted the
question is will he be acquitted
uh with any republican votes going
against him
or will he be acquitted with every
republican vote in his favor
remains to be seen join the discussion
on the subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit we've been talking recently about
the
improving numbers when it comes to covet
vaccine hesitancy
some months ago i months ago at this
point almost a year
back in may uh we had somewhere between
two thirds and three quarters of
americans hesitant about getting a
coronavirus vaccine
when it becomes available vaccines now
are available we have two vaccines
available a third one coming soon maybe
a fourth one coming soon
and the good news is that the vaccine
hesitancy
has declined as far as the covet vaccine
is concerned it got down to 50 percent
40 now about one third of americans
say they definitely or probably will not
get
the covid vaccine according to the
latest poll now
it's good that the hesitancy has
declined
but unfortunately especially when you're
not going to start vaccinating kids
for some period of time in order to get
hurt immunity particularly with these
more
contagious variants you need to have
close to every adult in the united
states vaccinated to get to
herd immunity so it's still a disaster
that one third of americans aren't
interested but this new poll did
something interesting
which is it actually broke down a
variety of groups political groups
racial groups based on education level
and
we have identified the most anti-coveted
vaccine groups in the country
and three of these groups are
republicans
those without a college degree and black
americans these are
three of the most anti-vaccine groups in
the united states
uh for different reasons importantly and
and members of these different
communities will have different reasons
for telling you
uh why they are skeptical of the vaccine
now the reasons
that people tend to cite as to why they
don't plan to get the coronavirus
vaccine
include concerns about side effects
not trusting the vaccines from a safety
standpoint
and not believing that they need the
vaccine
not trusting the government is another
reason and not knowing that the vaccine
not believing that the vaccine is
actually
effective so let's look at some of the
numbers here
black americans are significantly less
likely than white americans
to want the vaccine 57 percent
of black americans say they want the
vaccine compared to 68
of white americans um hispanic americans
very similar to white americans in that
uh
in that category now this to some degree
is probably related to uh historical uh
um
atrocities um that uh include
medical experimentation uh with black
americans
and a lot of my uh black facebook
friends have been posting
a lot about guys while we understand
the historical atrocities related to
experimentation we need this vaccine and
what we don't want is for our community
this is
not not me speaking but some of my black
friends on facebook saying we don't want
our community
to end up disproportionately
unvaccinated that will continue
uh to perpetuate these um unequal
outcomes when it comes to
vaccination when it comes to education
americans
without college degrees significantly
more
likely than college-educated americans
to
um not want the vaccine 40 of those
without college degrees
say no vaccine for me only 17
of those with college degrees say no
vaccine for me so
that's not surprising lack of education
and lack of just a real understanding of
how the vaccine works etc makes perfect
sense that
the the less educated you are the less
able to sort of parse the scientific
data or even know where to get it that
that makes perfect sense not surprising
and then of course republicans more
likely than democrats and independents
not to want the vaccine and that one is
pretty obvious
when you have had a party that from day
one
led by donald trump starting in when
when was it right january february
um played down the risk of the vaccine
of the uh coronavirus
um played up this idea of it's just the
flu
played up the idea of it's going away
soon played up the idea of that's that's
in china it's not going to go elsewhere
and of course we know that all of those
things were wrong
it makes sense that if you were part of
the political party that that
not only spread those ideas but actually
tried to use them
um to justify re-elections and that
failed at least for donald trump it
makes sense that you would be
less likely to want the vaccine why
would you need a vaccine against
something that your
party leaders have been telling you for
a year now is really not that serious in
the end so completely unsurprising as
far as that goes now
at some point we have to decide
um what are we going to do
if a significant portion of the
population never
gets vaccinated i do think that uh
various types of businesses
saying if you want to go to concerts we
organize
you'll have to have proof of vaccination
you don't have to get it
the government's not making you get it
we're not making you get it we're just
saying
if you want to do business with us a
private business who organizes concerts
or
flies people around or whatever you will
have to choose to go
and get the vaccine i do think that that
will have
an impact but there are lots of people
who just
aren't going to get it unless something
significant changes i don't know what
that's going to be at this point in time
um and it's something we'll have to
continue talking about
let me know if you're surprised by any
of these numbers any of these groups
that are the most vaccine hesitant we'll
have more about this on the david pakman
show instagram which you can find
at david pakman show and while you're
there follow me on instagram
at david.pacman as well the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all
means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today michael kinch who is associate
vice chancellor at washington university
in st louis and also author of between
hope and
fear which is a history of vaccines it's
so great to have you on today
thanks the opportunity so we could start
in so many different places but let's
let's maybe start with something that's
a big topic of discussion
right now um we've seen sort of
different numbers stated about what the
goal should be in terms of the
percentage of
of americans or or of global citizens
but maybe we'll start with americans
that
need to be vaccinated in order for the
u.s to approximate what would be called
herd immunity and of course there's a
number of input
factors that determine what this number
should be how contagious
something is uh how effective the
vaccines are and all of these other
things
what's what are the sort of the most
important things we should be thinking
about now in terms of
the variance in terms of vaccine
hesitancy all of these different input
factors
for if there is this this one number
that we should be looking at as
as the sort of threshold yes
and herd immunity is a term that has
actually been
misidentified and misused particularly
by the previous administration and in a
nutshell it's the likelihood that if
you're someone who is susceptible let's
say you were a cancer patient
who had chemotherapy that knocked down
your immune system what is the
likelihood that you will encounter
someone
in your vicinity that might infect you
and that number for
sarskav 2 the current source of the
pandemic
has been creeping upwards it started at
about 70 percent and it looks like today
it's probably between 80 and 85 percent
in part because these new variants the
british variant and the south african
variant not to mention a brazilian
variant that hasn't gotten as much press
are far more communicative so i think we
need to be shooting for 85 percent
and from a realistic standpoint that
means that we need to have
probably 90 to 95 percent of the
population protected
because again some people will have had
cancer therapy
rheumatoid arthritis treatment they're
simply old
very old or very young and they may be
immunized but the immunization may not
take
and so we're going to have to go in
excess of that 80 to 85 percent number
in order to assure
that we finally get this virus behind us
now this this may be
uh a silly question but i've not heard
it addressed head-on necessarily
when we talk about these numbers i
presume we're talking about the entire
population
if you are not including people below a
certain age at least initially
don't we really need a hundred percent
of eligible adults because there are so
many people
under 18 or 16 which are the ages that
the pfizer and moderna vaccines
respectively have been tested on
don't we really need every adult
vaccinated
we do and um essentially again that 85
number alone means that we need that the
vaccines are being tested
in pediatric populations but we don't
have the data yet
right and so every adult in order to
protect your children and your
grandchildren really needs to be
vaccinated soon and as you mentioned
it's not just here in the us it's around
the world
because when you look at it as we've
seen we have
variants coming out of south africa and
other countries
and that means that someone in one
country
or a population in one country that
decides not to be vaccinated could
actually jeopardize the rest of the
planet
on uh on today's program one of the
things we looked at
was uh a new study that looked at the
current level of vaccine hesitancy in
the american population the the good top
line news is that
the 60 65 hesitancy of may 2020 has
been reduced dramatically it's that now
down according to this latest study
about a third of the country when you
slice and dice different groups
three groups that are particularly are
disproportionately vaccine hesitant when
it comes to
this vaccination are uh
among political lines republicans among
racial lines black americans
and among educational lines those
without a college degree
four different reasons these three
groups seem to be hesitant of the
vaccine for different reasons
what historically have been some of the
most effective ways to get more buy-in
to mass vaccination campaigns
i think there are two things one is that
we need to be 100 transparent both in
what we know
and what we don't know we're not here to
sell a used car we're here to get past
the pandemic
and so i think that we need to convey
when there is information that we don't
know about
we need to convey that but we also need
to convey what we do know and we need to
stop
rumors uh there have been rumors that
are completely unsubstantiated about
causing lack of female fertility or lack
of male fertility
and many other things but we also need
to respect that there are certain
populations of people
for example black americans that were
subjected for example to the tuskegee
experiments
right and that means that they're
hesitant about many different
standardized medical procedures and we
need to then explain to them
here is what we know about it and why
you're not being an experimental subject
but this is important and that gets to
the second thing we can do
to minimize the anti-vaxx movement and
that is to
people it's been shown will be more
amenable to being vaccinated as someone
that they knew
was vaccinated and if it went well and
so the more that we get into those
populations the better it should turn
out
the um one of the uh
concerns i have and i'm wondering
whether you share it
is that there are many articles that
from my perspective
are underselling the benefits of in
particular the two vaccines that are
approved right now and sometimes you
will see
maybe not headlines but like sub
headlines
that will say even when vaccinated
nobody can do anything differently
everything has to remain the same for a
very long time and
when you sometimes get into the details
or look at the blogs
of immunologists as an example you will
actually see much more interesting
information
like listen there is going to be some
risk no matter what
but a small group of vaccinated adults
10 days past dose number 2 is at
very low risk to do an indoor gathering
in particular if everybody works from
home you know
more sort of like meat on the bone about
there really are some differences and
this is a game changer and it will be
more of one as more people get
vaccinated
do you think my concern is is warranted
about the underselling of the vaccines
it is although again we don't want to
come across to selling a used car
right but i think you look at it these
vaccines are truly miraculous
the the magnitude of efficacy and
frankly safety as well
is far beyond what any of us thought a
year ago we would be able to achieve
especially within this time frame and i
would say it's better than the apollo
mission
that being said we are underselling it
and i think that
the proper way to address this what you
just mentioned which is very valid
is to say look we don't yet know
after you're vaccinated whether you
might be able to communicate virus to
others
and we want to communicate to people the
last thing that you want to do
is to unintentionally infect your
grandparents your children your
grandchildren
sure and so just to be safe let's keep
up those safety measures until we have
established herd immunity
and let's be clear what herd immunity
really means and i think most reasonable
people
will say oh if i'm protecting my
neighbors by doing this
that that's a great reason to do it not
that it's this onerous thing that we
have to continue to do
you were talking about the republican
pushback to vaccination
this is simply a continuation of the
denial that the pandemic was real the
denial that the masks
affect are effective and we have to get
past that and say look
independent of what your political views
are here's what the science tells us
what uh is the best way for someone
to um accurately sort of parse
as you talk about so many rumors every
single day there's something the modern
vaccine doesn't work against the south
african variant oh it does but it just
is more borderline in terms of the
immunity versus being more robust
against the uk variant and oh well maybe
that's not true
uh we need to get to one level of herd
immunity versus another and then the
next day we find out oh the number is
actually different
for the average person particularly
people not like me who do this for a
living but people who have other jobs
where they can't follow this stuff
necessarily that that closely
what's the best way to stay up on what
the sort of top line realities are about
cases about deaths about vaccination
treatment etc
well now that the centers for disease
control and prevention
is under capable hands again i think
that you can go back to trusting them
frankly
this we had the best um public health
group on the planet
until the the this pandemic broke out
and they lost a lot of their credibility
and i frankly was telling people don't
listen to cdc because they weren't
giving the right information
but i would say if you had one go-to
reliable place it would be the cdc
otherwise don't google go
for example to mayo clinic or go to
whatever your local hospital has to say
look what they
have to say google and twitter
i mean one of the amazing things is that
if you look at the anti-vaxx movement
not just for this
pandemic but mmr and other vaccines
it is discomforting to know that about
85 to 90 percent of
the tweets that are anti-vaxx are coming
from russian troll farms
and all they are doing is really
undermining and their intent is to
undermine belief in authorities
and so i have not naive belief in
authorities but especially the cdc it's
turned itself around just in the past
few weeks
still got a lot of room to make up but
go to the major universities other
places that are not
making money or profiting in any way
from this
for the most part the pharma companies
have actually been surprisingly
transparent there have been some
exceptions and i've been a big critic of
the exceptions
and we need to be critics of the
exceptions and but i would say that
most people so far have come together
and been mostly responsible
when it comes to vaccines per day when
joe biden was
just days from being sworn in he was
talking about a million a day for a
hundred days of course
at the time the approved vaccines are
are two doses meaning you're talking
about vaccinating 50 million people
we're now hopefully getting closer to
the approval of the jnj
vaccine which will be a one dose and
then there's potentially more more
vaccines coming
um when when you're looking at this i
mean it seems to me that with a third
vaccine
two and a half to three million doses a
day total
is is reasonable which seems like it
would be a major accomplishment but
we're still talking about months there
in the best of cases
until everybody can get vaccinated what
sort of numbers are you looking at
i mean i think the the the two key
numbers to remember
are 350 million americans right which
if we forget the jnj vaccine for a
minute that means 700 million doses
which is a lot and this is a brand new
technology
but then the other number is seven and a
half billion humans
which then means 15 billion doses and
again this isn't over until it's
completely over
now i believe in hope that the jnj
vaccine is likely to be approved based
on on what we've seen
right um its efficacy numbers are again
very impressive they're not quite up to
the mrna vaccine numbers but
at least it could get someone some
transient protection if you will
and and future studies can determine
well maybe someone who got one vaccine
will need a boost of another
but i the the most remarkable thing
about the vaccine numbers is not
necessarily just the magnitude of
efficacy
which is exceeding at this point 95 and
based on the israeli study it may be
closer to 99.5
right but it's the fact that
the disease severity is greatly reduced
and people frankly are not dying
or getting severe disease and that's
where we want to be if you're stuck with
feeling bad for a few days or getting a
cold which most grind of coronaviruses
cause a cold
that's infinitely better than having to
be intubated and and
lord forbid pass away or have your
relatives do so so i would say the big
numbers now are we've got to ramp up
production
the need now the concern now is not
anti-vaxx the concern
is manufacturing and making sure that
the manufacturing quality still stays
high
and that's where again fda has been very
consistent and fantastic about doing
that
there have been uh some uh preprints
based in some cases almost on accidental
circumstances that have surfaced
which suggest and again i want to be
careful to make clear that we're talking
about something we're still learning
about which suggests
that in some cases if at the time that
the second dose would be given you just
kept waiting
you would get a very close level of
protection to what you get
from the second dose plus 7 to 14 days
is that an interesting path that you
think needs to be looked at in terms of
of possibly being able to expand the
number of people inoculated with the
vaccines we're expecting to have
if the data show it i think that we
run a risk there was a there was
discussion about giving everybody one
shot
right and even if it falls outside the
window uh that was done in the clinical
trials
um giving them a later shot we just
frankly don't have the data to say
whether that's useful or not and the
situation we don't want to end up in
is that we give everyone one shot and
one shot turns out to be insufficient
and we have to start
and turn around and begin afresh right
now everyone needs to get two shots even
if you already had one
and we just don't that we have to be
guided by the data
um we the last administration was
frustrating because they didn't seem to
want to track any data
um and this administration i think is
open to it but there's going to be
pressure to hit these artificial numbers
i would say 100 million in 100 days is
great all i care about is
as many as can be safely done that's the
number we need to get
and hopefully that'll be well in excess
of 100 million no doubt about it yeah
and 2 million last saturday and 2
million last sunday certainly are are
great
great great numbers to start seeing
we've been speaking
with michael kinch author of between
hope and fear a history of vaccines also
associate vice chancellor at washington
university in st
louis a such a pleasure having you on i
really appreciate your time
thank you so much the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this
point and the daily commercial free tv
show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so as we've seen donald trump's second
impeachment trial get into day two and
then now into day three there have been
a lot of questions about just what has
donald trump
actually been doing these last few days
and even the couple of weeks since he
left office and there's a very
interesting
new article in the washington post from
josh dossey and ashley parker that tells
the story of donald trump at mar-a-lago
in palm beach florida
doing a lot of golfing not surprisingly
doing a lot of just
calling old friends and trying to
reconnect with people he reportedly
continues to have many political aids on
his payroll just around him
sycophants of sorts of different kinds
uh but this washington post article
really tells the story of a
former president and former sort of big
shot businessman at least
at least to some degree whose world is
really crumbling around him increasingly
isolated from most of uh
of popular culture half the country or
more
disgusted with him unwilling to
patronize his businesses anymore
and while as josh dossey writes in the
washington
post trump is confident that he is going
to be
acquitted uh he is increasingly
disturbed
partially by the absolutely bizarre
performance of his attorney bruce castor
on monday
uh the free association uh rorschach
test sort of thing that took place which
we covered yesterday
uh trump disappointed in bruce castor's
performance
uh donald trump also uh reportedly
um not pleased in general with how
republicans have been
uh some republicans have been responding
to the evidence presented
so far and uh donald trump is in this
sort of bubble and we know that donald
trump was in a bubble while he was
president of the united states
but he seems to sort of further be
protecting himself with this bubble
uh and part of it interestingly enough
is coming from the fact that donald
trump
is banned from a lot of social media
platforms were donald trump not banned
from twitter right now
he would be not only tweeting but also
spending more time on twitter and maybe
seeing that there are even many
republicans disgusted with donald
trump's role
in inciting the riots on january 6th the
fact that donald trump
has been removed from twitter and a
number of other platforms
has placed him in what many people
around him are saying
a it is a state of being adrift no
idea of what to do day to day no idea of
what comes next
and whether there is a future for donald
trump's political life and business life
and i think this is another aspect that
it just sort of remains to be seen like
does donald trump go back to
doing real estate deals at this point
the one thing
that has been mentioned by a number of
sources that dossie and parker cite in
their washington post piece is that
donald trump
is calmer than was expected he was
reportedly screaming
about bruce castor's terrible
performance
but trump seems relatively calm as he is
adrift and unclear about what the future
is of his business
and political life uh but donald trump
reportedly
furious with some republicans including
congresswoman liz cheney who did vote to
impeach donald trump in the house of
representatives
house republican leader kevin mccarthy
who said trump does have some
responsibility for the attack on the
capital then ended up backtracking when
those comments exploded so the the
general sense here
is that this is a trump uh surrounded by
the most extreme sycophants because who
else would be left at this point
to even be around donald trump given
what's taken place
off social media partially because he's
been kicked off
furious with the republicans that he
believes have abandoned him
and unclear as to what the future of his
life
uh even is at this point in time now one
other interesting detail about donald
trump during
the impeachment trial and in the days
leading up
early on you'll remember that a bunch of
donald trump's uh
lawyers for the second impeachment trial
quit it was i guess
a week ago sunday not this past sunday
but the previous one
part of what we believe led to that is
that donald trump was insisting to his
first legal team that they defend
trump in the impeachment trial by
arguing that trump's claims about a
stolen election were
were true this is sort of like a an
affirmative defense
um if you're accused of uh killing
someone and you're being charged with
murder
one defense would be i didn't do it i
just
i didn't kill anybody an affirmative
defense would be
i did kill them but it's not murder
because it was self-defense
and what donald trump wanted was the
affirmative defense of okay yeah
i did tell people to go to the capitol
and they were being inspired by me
but it was because i rightly identified
that the election was stolen
from me trump's initial uh defense team
reportedly thought that that was an
absolutely terrible idea
uh knowing donald trump's instinct for
self-sabotage and inflicting
you know unforced unforced problems upon
himself
uh they didn't go with that and donald
trump ultimately
getting new lawyers but that is not the
case that is being made and the case
that we
we have already seen previewed by donald
trump's attorneys bruce castor and david
shone
and which we are going to continue to
see uh today and as the
defense mounts um are simply that donald
trump didn't incite the riot
period and uh that another source of
isolation
and fury and confusion from donald trump
so i don't know what the future of
donald trump's life is
what i hope happens is that the country
can move on from trump but
at the same time and we're going to talk
about this on the friday show
i do actually hope for the sake of the
left that donald trump tries to start a
third party
because so many republicans have said in
in surveys
that they'd be willing to abandon the
republican party and follow trump trump
starting a third party
could be exactly what the left needs to
really make some progress over the next
two
four six even eight years so we'll be
talking more about that on tomorrow's
program
hey this is really it's either funny or
depressing
or horrifying i guess it depends on your
mood at the time
but it's definitely notable in the last
two days
of the trump impeachment trial number
two
we've seen stunning footage of what took
place
on january 6th including plenty of
previously unreleased
footage video of senators like chuck
schumer and others
being escorted out by security and just
barely avoiding an
angry trumpist mob that in some cases
you see a senator escorted out
and then the mob comes by in the hallway
just seconds
after a senator was escorted out and now
it's undeniable the stunning reality of
what took place
and we now know that there are some
defenses that simply
wouldn't hold this wasn't really a big
deal
no members of congress were really under
threat
those defenses don't work anymore
because we've seen all of the footage
but we are now starting to see some
like fox news propagandist tucker
carlson shift to a different type of
argument
and tucker is shifting to you know it's
all so confusing
it's impossible to know what really
happened on january 6th
but it definitely has to do with black
lives matter
what i'm not kidding let's look at some
video
of tucker carlson's show discussing the
subject matter presented during the
trump impeachment trial this week
and uh he very quickly gets into oh we
just we just don't know it's impossible
to know but we're definitely being lied
to
so what does all of this mean exactly
we're not sure what it means and we're
not going to speculate
we do know for certain that the known
facts of what happened on january 6th
deviate in very important ways from the
story they are now telling us including
the story they told us today in the
impeachment hearings
we don't know what it means and we don't
speculate
but what you're being told definitely
isn't true but wait hold on tucker hold
wait a second if you have no idea what
happened
and it's impossible to know what really
happened how do you know
that the videos and statements so far
aren't true and then
you know what's coming let's take a look
and in many places the known facts
bear no resemblance to the story they're
telling they're just flat out lying
there's no question about that the
question is why would they lie about
this
for an answer think back to last spring
beginning of memorial day blm and their
sponsors in corporate america
completely changed this country they
changed this country more in five months
than it had changed in the previous 50
years
so now it's we don't know what happened
it's impossible to know
but not only is tucker sure that he's
been lied to
he knows that to understand what
happened on january 6th we have to look
at black lives matter protests from nine
months ago
what i sometimes jokingly will talk
about how one of the reasons why
populist rhetoric can be so dangerous
and deceptive and pernicious
is that populist rhetoric on the left
and right sounds very similar
and you can fall into it and then
suddenly the solutions you get from
these right-wing
so-called populists are crazy like
we have to make sure black lives matter
doesn't steal your house and we've got
to stop brown people from coming into
the united states
tucker is actually doing it he's not
sure what happened on january 6th and he
wants
the people to know the truth we we can't
have elites lying to us about what
took place and despite all of the video
evidence and trump inciting it
he doesn't know whether we can even
really know what happened but he's sure
that what black lives matter did eight
nine months ago protesting the death of
george floyd
that's part of what happened what let's
continue
how'd they do that they used the sad
death of a man called george floyd
to upend our society months later we
learned that the story they told us
about george floyd's death
was an utter lie there was no physical
evidence that george floyd was murdered
by a cop
the autopsy showed that george floyd
almost certainly died of a drug overdose
fentanyl now tucker mentions as an aside
george floyd died of a drug overdose
dose
that's not what's been determined that's
a lie tucker carlson's lying to you
the truth is that the medical examiner's
office ruled
that the manner of george floyd's death
was
homicide it was a homicide the cause of
death
according to the medical examiner was
what was described as quote
cardiopulmonary arrest complicating
law enforcement subdual restraint and
neck compression
it did also mention conditions
related to floyd's death
arteriosclerotic and hypertensive heart
disease
he was not a healthy guy from a
cardiovascular standpoint
fentanyl intoxication and recent
methamphetamine use
but tucker is lying here the medical
examiner didn't say
that what happened wasn't a homicide or
that what happened wasn't related to
what police officers
did to george floyd he's lying to you
while telling you
that other people are lying to you and
that the january 6th riot it's just too
complicated to understand let's look at
a little more
but by that point facts didn't matter it
was too late
cities had been destroyed along with the
fabric of this country itself
scores of people had been killed
democratic partisans used a carefully
concocted myth
a lie to bum rush america into
overturning the old order
and handing them much more power it
worked
flawlessly so why wouldn't they do it
again
and then more and more lies the george
flowed floyd protests
were important they were significant
they received media attention
but what social or cultural order did
they overturn
billionaires continued to get richer and
richer during an economic downturn and
global pandemic
wealth continued to concentrate at the
top corporations are still in total
control of american society and the
economy
and we continue to see regulatory
capture what order
did the protests overturn yeah i mean
they raised awareness of issues
they created new activists but what
world order was upended
it didn't happen and of course not only
is tucker carlson lying
he's lying to make you forget about the
fact that he's saying oh that january
6th situation
we can't really know what happened it's
just too complicated it's too difficult
to know but you're definitely being lied
to
it's incredible and sad that this guy
is a hero to so many people who
unquestioningly believe
everything he says and it's going to get
worse we've we've predicted that right
wing media is going to be off the rails
for the next two years
and it's getting worse and worse we have
a voicemail number which is 2192 david p
i've gotten a lot of questions about i
know that this
is it sounds unbelievable but the right
now has a new date
on which they believe trump is going to
come to power
the conspiracy right they believe it's
march 4th here's a viewer
uh asking about it oh yes david this is
alan calling for texas and i've been
reading a
bunch of stuff online about march the
4th
mm-hmm being the day that cubanon
believes donald trump will come back
into power
right and it has to do with
a law that changed
the date when the argue inauguration of
the president
uh yes when it moved from march to
january that's exactly right there are
some q anon types that are floating a
pretty convoluted
conspiracy theory which says trump is
going to be re-inaugurated
on march 4th and he's going to be
president of the united states and what
what this comes from is that before 1937
presidents would be inaugurated on march
4th
and then it was changed by the 20th
amendment to january 20th
so there are q anon types and sovereign
citizen types
and some of the fringe groups that talk
about a deep state and all these
different things
they are uh claiming
that on um march
4th under a restored republic
that will go back to the sort of
presidential timeline
of presidents inaugurated on march 4th
prior to 1937
trump's going to be sworn in that i i
hope i'm doing justice to something
completely crazy that doesn't even
deserve justice being done but that's my
understanding of the theory
and it's not going to happen we were
told that by december 14th
trump was going to be the uh apparent
winner the president-elect
we were told then by january 6th it was
going to be we were told that something
would happen by january 20th joe biden's
president joe biden will be president on
march 4th
and 5th and 6th and 7th and on uh but
yes they there's always something and to
be honest
i actually don't know if these
conspiracy theories are being created
um because there's money in it for
somebody like is there a financial
incentive here where people are somehow
monetizing these theories
or is it really just people desperate
not to accept reality i don't know the
answer to that
we will talk about the dallas mavericks
uh
national anthem controversy on today's
bonus show we will talk about joe biden
policy with china we will talk about
those stories and much more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources
are influencing the news you read
download the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground